on dirait peut-être pas comme ça mais
cette petite bête fait ses 100 ans cette
année bon c'est vrai elle ne les fait
pas pourtant c'est bien ce weekend que
la géline de Touren soufflera sa cè
bougie en effet c'est en 1913 que cette
race de volaille est homologuée une
homologation qui s'appuie sur des
critères bien particuliers alors il doit
avoir la crête bien rouge les barbillons
c'est ce qu' pens sous son bec doit être
bien rouge et ce qu'on appelle
l'oreillon doit avoir du blanc à
l'intérieur les pattes doivent être gris
ardoises c'est la particularité si vous
voulez de de la géum de curen c'est des
1909 que Jean-Baptiste Martin un
professeur départemental d'agriculture
tente de faire sortir de l'oubli celle
que l'on appelle aussi la noire de
Touren et à force d'abnégation il
obtient un gain de cause et le Bureau
central des sociétés d'aviculture de
France l'homologue le 12 novembre 1913
si aujourd'hui les éleveurs de géine de
Touren se font de plus en plus rare dans
la région ell n'en restent pas moins
très recherché la géine de Touren est
une excellente pondeuse elle fait
environ 170 à 80 u dans une année pour
des vieilles races c'est beaucoup c'est
même très bien et en plus c'est une des
meilleures volailles c'est une des
meilleures volailles au point de vue
gastronomique elle est utilisée par
beaucoup de chef étoilés et si la géine
a été homologuée il y a si longtemps ce
n'était pas encore le cas du laping gris
de Touren chose qui sera corrigée des ce
weekend une délégation sera en effet
présente au centenaire pour officialiser
tout ça la Touren deviendra ainsi la
région donnant le plus son nom à des
races animales puisqu'il existe aussi
une noix de Touren